temp or two was so full of Easter eggs
inside jokes and obscure gags that
nobody could possibly catch them all
which is great because it means that
every time you watch it there's another
layer to discover to help you on that
journey
here's a look at some of the smallest
details in Deadpool - you might not have
noticed until now up an atom therefore -
super duper kurt released the home
audiences restored a bunch of deleted
scenes to the film but there was one
truly random joke that didn't make it
into any version of the film during the
sequence where Wade Wilson sets
altimeters to cease love Vanessa in the
afterlife by killing himself over and
over again there was originally an
unexpected homage to the beloved Pixar
film up it's a free country you're right
it is the movies do oddly enough share a
lot of thematic elements so there's the
thesis for next term paper you're
welcome
the true juggernaut unlike his
appearance in 2006 is x-men the last and
the super strong super large character
juggernaut was completely
computer-generated in deep water but if
you were wondering who played the role
the end credits weren't very helpful
they claimed that the film featured the
real juggernaut playing himself turns
out the truth is even weirder the facial
motion capture was actually provided by
director david leitch while Ryan
Reynolds himself did both the voice and
the motion capture for the body meaning
in many scenes who was actually fighting
himself it was such a big secret that
even co-stars to fawn capitulum ocean
capture for colossus didn't know about
her he told The Hollywood Reporter Ryan
is always there when I'm working on
Colossus helping me with the lines and
giving me ideas then I saw Ryan getting
into the CGI costume and I'm like what's
going on man did I miss something rubs
the wrong way one of the deleted scenes
that ended up in tempo - super duper cut
is a serene domestic sequence in the
opulence Xavier mansion in which Wade
Wilson tries to endear himself to his
new roommates following callosities
intervention and his mission to
self-destruct something wrong it's fine
I just filled it give it a few more
pumps there
on its own the scene seems like a non
sequitur but it's actually setting up a
truly repulsive punch line later in the
movie people think you wake up a hero
brush your teeth a hero ejaculate into a
soap dispenser a hero the punchline
actually appeared in the final film
without a setup so if you are confused
now you know the secret behind this
seemingly random moment star-studded
breakfast in a quick moment during the
first fight of the villainous Essex
House Deadpool pauses after being held
through a window to sign an autograph
for a child who never actually asked the
one grabbing a pen in a cereal box he
scribbles across the front of the box
before jumping back in the fray
you've probably noticed that the box of
hero flakes has an image of Hugh
Jackman's Wolverine on the front but in
a visual gag that might have gone by too
fast to see the first time that Paul
actually signed his real name Ryan
Reynolds we know this rivalry with
Wolverine comes from a place of hate and
all but as uninvolved viewers it all
comes off as kind of cute double dipped
alternate jokes
therefore to SuperDuper curt is less of
a definitive director's cut and more of
an alternate longer version of the movie
replete with different jokes some of
which were improvised by the actors and
some of which was scripted there's a
reason why I'm here and I'll know when I
know everything usually just kind of
works out for me like 2008 Ryan Reynolds
I don't know who that is you're hired
my Nelson ganged apparently couldn't
decide what strokes were funniest
so instead they just released two
different versions of the movie so you
could get all the jokes the opening
credits are a perfect example with
different punchlines that don't change
the story at all but give repeat
viewings a new twist and some of the
changes like the placing the finger gun
with a real gun didn't seem to serve any
purpose at all which is really the most
Deadpool move of all when you think
about it Red Lotus as director david
leitch puts it drawing a special
features interview there might be easter
eggs hiding inside Deadpool too that no
viewer will ever discover there's so
many to dig into in layers of them that
I don't think anyone will ever find them
I challenge you to find them just help
deeper some of these cuts take a look at
this business card briefly seen before
the opening action montage when
translated the text is actually a
reference to an obscure x-men character
named Red Lotus who is a super-powered
Australian with ties to a Chinese crime
family in
the words not only do you need an
encyclopedic knowledge of x-men law to
catch the reference you also need to be
fluent in Cantonese so what other
secrets are hiding in Deadpool so cue up
google translate and get to work we
can't wait to see what you might find
[Music]